I got approached to work on this very
short-term project in Washington DC and
I said no thanks I got asked a second
time I said that's great but no thanks
and then a third time is kind of a
personal favor and so I said yes of
course
turns out I went down for one week one
week turned into two weeks two weeks
turned into three months and instead of
going back to Harvard I went to
Afghanistan you're listening to the
Microsoft Research podcast a show that
brings you closer to the cutting edge of
technology research and the scientists
behind it I'm your host Gretchen using
[Applause]
when we think of metals we usually
picture them over the pocket of a
military hero not over the pocket
protector of a computer scientist that
may be because not many academics end up
working with the Department of Defense
the doctor Chris White now a principal
researcher at Microsoft Research has and
he's received several awards for his
efforts in fighting terrorism and crime
with big data statistics and machine
learning today dr. white talks about his
problem first approach to research
explains the vital importance of making
data understandable for everyone and
shares the story of how a one-week
detour from academia turned into an
extended tour in Afghanistan a stint at
DARPA
and eventually a career at Microsoft
Research that and much more on this
episode of the Microsoft Research
podcast
[Music]
Chris white welcome to the podcast hi
Gretchen Thanks so you're a principal
researcher at MSR and you work on
special projects we'll talk about that
in a second what that means but for now
let's talk in general about what gets
you up in the morning what are the big
problems you're working on and the big
questions that you're asking well
there's a bunch of questions and
problems worth looking at and from my
point of view I looked at problems that
were happening in society problems that
technology companies could build
technology to address technology that
could also have a business purpose and
it sort of inspires me in lots of ways
one way to think about it is you know
what does terrorist financing human
trafficking propaganda ransomware what
do those have in common well those are
all things that appear online and they
appear in the vastness of big data and
the darkness of usernames and so if one
we're trying to address those problems
technology would be a helpful aid and a
company like Microsoft who has a huge
technology platform and has the
responsibility to maintain trust
worldwide would be a great place to work
on it so the term research covers a
broad range of approaches to discovery
finding stuff out more colloquially and
the special projects approach you bring
to the mix here by way of the Defense
Advanced Research Project agency or
DARPA is a little different from
traditional academic research can you
talk about that how is this approach
different what advantages does it offer
for specific kinds of research questions
sure one way to think about research is
not knowing what you're doing research
right and given that there are many ways
to approach solving problems that you
don't know how to solve sometimes the
question depends on the scope of the
problem sometimes it depends on the
maturity of the approaches to solve the
problem
sometimes it depends on the state of
society and its ability to adopt and use
and afford solutions to problems and so
a DARPA the way it's approached is by
identifying the problem first and then
understanding how to organize money
technology talent people organization
to best execute against solving that
problem and that usually means that you
assemble lots of different kinds of
people as opposed to a classical view of
research from the academic point of view
where you study a problem you write
papers that are reviewed by your peers
and you advance the field by that kind
of approach in the projects kind of
approach you bring together people with
different skills and then you organize
them to approach a problem with larger
scope that you could address as a single
person and the hope is that you can do
something impactful yeah do you find
purchase with that method as they say
for sure in my world we work on data
analytics we work on how to enable
people to interact with computers to
make decisions from information we want
them to have helped from AI and we focus
on how to help them organize and
structure information and how to help
them interact and visualize that to make
decisions to do that requires people
with different backgrounds it requires
user interface application developers it
requires big data distributed computing
developers it requires people familiar
with machine learning and artificial
intelligence techniques any one of those
people can address part of the problem
but to address it and to end requires
organizing them together and so that's
the projects approach we take here ok
let's talk about data science writ large
for a minute the massive amounts in
multiple sources of data that we have
today have prompted it need for big data
analytics and data visualization tools
so what are the specific challenges of
big data problems and how are you
tackling them well big data much like
artificial intelligence are terms that
are vague yeah in fact they don't mean
anything neither big nor data they're
not qualified just like artificial
intelligence and so that's good and bad
you know it's good because there's a
movement that movement has funding and
interest from policy makers it has the
need for understanding implications but
that movement is still very large and
very vague and so I think about big data
really in terms of publicly accessible
information as a starting point
because that's something people are
familiar with they've all gone to a
search bar they've all issued a bunch of
queries they've all had a bunch of
browser tabs open and had that familiar
feeling of gathers just like a lot of
information out there how do I find what
I need how do I organize it and when
that problem is a business problem it's
even bigger yeah and so I think of it
like that sometimes there's images like
an iceberg where what you see from a
search bar what you see if you did a
being search for a product or a
celebrity or an event and you get a list
of links in an answer card they think of
that as data interaction and it's true
but behind that there's a lot more there
are databases there are api's with
streams like Twitter and Facebook there
are public records from FOIA results
there are all kinds of things that you
have to have a different kind of skill
to access and a lot of the big data
approaches are how to use technology to
access that information and how to
present it to people so they can make
use of it one way I think about it
sometimes is I go all the way back to
the beginning of computers 1830s Charles
Babbage is envisioning a computational
machine of some kind and the end one
gets built they calls it the difference
engine and really that was an engine
that let you compare numbers but what
it's happening now is the same
fundamental operation of comparison but
it's not zeros and ones people want to
compare concept like entities they want
to compare events they want to
understand the reaction to things and
those are the kinds of questions you can
answer with big data it's not a fact
it's more understanding the situation
understanding what's happening who's
involved how to do the analysis and
those are the Empowered abilities we
want our users to have what's your
particular focus in the machine learning
space right so I view the process has
one where people are more or less doing
the same thing they've always been doing
in the world but what's changed is now
we have lots of more partial and noisy
observations of that behavior and with
that we can start to infer what was
going on and what to do about it
what's changing
and so we view that process through the
lens of data analysis how do we take in
lots of partial noisy observations from
streams of sensors like social media
like news like web pages and documents
internal reports measurements of various
kinds to organize them in a way that
lets people understand what might have
been going on and to understand what
might be related and what they might be
able to do about it and so we employ
methods of graph analysis and graph two
to six to posit a data generating
process that we can measure and then to
evaluate that as a good representation
and then to bridge to the user we find
us not enough so we need ways to
visualize and explain it those require
advances and inventions in that visual
space of representation and in the space
of interaction and so we have focused in
that space as well so I say that in a
way my home is in machine learning and
information theory and I'm a tourist in
the HCI space but really now there's
like a second home when I went overseas
I was there to do a machine learning
problem it turned out that I needed to
do visualization and HCI because people
wouldn't use the results if they didn't
understand them people wouldn't take
advantage and take action on information
if they couldn't interrogate it and so
very quickly that process of
visualization of interaction of
application development became as
important if not more than the machine
learning algorithms to transform data
into a data structure for use and so we
continued focusing on advances in
modeling that are more realistic that
are more efficient they're more
expressive as well as advances in HCI
they're more representative that have
more points of view for interaction that
allow for different kinds of users to
understand things more quickly to have
less training material and tutorial and
those are the basis for our research
[Music]
let's go back a little bit you have a
fascinating background talk about that
for a minute well I grew up in the
Midwest and in Oklahoma and focused on
Electrical Engineering and over time
became more and more academic I'm got a
PhD and did a post doctoral fellowship
was planning to be a faculty that's kind
of what you get taught to do when you're
in that kind of schooling and I got
approached to work on this very
short-term project in Washington DC and
I said no thanks I was really enjoying
the summer in Cambridge I got asked a
second time said it was good for my
professional development I said that's
great but no thanks and then a third
time is kind of a personal favor and so
I said yes of course it turns out I went
down for one week one week turned into
two weeks two weeks turned into three
months and instead of going back to
Harvard I went to Afghanistan and that
began a very odd detour into fieldwork
where the reality of people using
technology to understand information and
make decisions really dramatically
affected me and the way that I think
about problem-solving and waiting about
research that led to several years of
understanding and fielding technology
for use in the Middle East understanding
how people adopt technology what they
need how they prioritize their problems
and then all of those lessons got to
come back with me and be part of major
investments for DARPA that included X
data which is a program that was part of
President Obama's big data initiative it
was the lead project for DARPA and Memex
which is titled after than of our Bush's
famous article as we may think where he
anticipated Wikipedia and hyperlinks and
he describes this machine called MMX
that lets you dig into information and
make sense of it and the open catalog
which lets us publish and share the
results from research funded by
taxpayers at DARPA nice and all of these
my view is that if we're investing
taxpayer dollars unless there's a
compelling security reason to keep
something secret we should make it free
and easy to access
and those projects those were
opportunities to invest in small
companies large companies universities
to bring both general purpose technology
but then to bring it together to solve
important problems like human
trafficking and terrorism financing
let's talk about that for a minute
you went from doing military work in
Afghanistan to digital crime fighting
can you talk about that era of your life
firm sure many of these technologies
data analysis technologies machine
learning technologies human computer
interfaces these are very general again
they're almost like utilities from my
point of view that's why having them as
open source projects makes a lot of
sense to me or having them as low cost
products makes a lot of sense to me and
the observation coming back from
Afghanistan was that many parts of the
government had similar problems and
there were many law enforcement and
related organizations that had similar
problems and so we decided to pick a few
of those and focus on them as
applications knowing that if we could
address those as well as build
general-purpose technology than other
people might help apply them to other
problems and coming from the government
to Microsoft there was a real
opportunity and therefore we thought
this is a great place to work on that
problem we have a Digital Crimes Unit we
have the ability to apply those
techniques we've learned and we have the
technology platforms that Microsoft has
so we took a shot at it and well the
first problem we worked on with the
Digital Crimes Unit was a cousin problem
to ransomware there's a version of that
problem called tech scams and that works
like this you're on your computer and
either you click on something or you get
an email or somehow your computer gets
into a state where there's a pop-up that
says whoa hey you have a virus you need
to call tech support and here's the
number call it now first of all none of
you should ever do that ever call tech
support if you're prompted to from a
computer it doesn't work that way and
you're gonna get in trouble we get tens
of thousands of complaints in writing a
month where people say there was this
thing that popped up on my computer
pop lips pop lips pop lips pop tops
wouldn't go away wouldn't go away
wouldn't go away couldn't delete it
couldn't get rid of
and then what happens have to buy
security software have to give
credentials have to lose control of the
computer someone using it remotely all
these kinds of things and it's just a
difficult situation and so this problem
it's pervasive it's something like you
know one in twelve people that were
interviewed had this problem happened to
them and of those many of them were
ensnared and so we took on this problem
and the way we approached it was by
building a web scale crawling
architecture to find where all of these
scams are happening on webpages anywhere
and this is not easy no this is at the
same scale as crawling the web to build
a search index it doesn't have the same
difficulties in one sense because you're
not enabling millions or billions of
people to access that simultaneously
which is a very hard operational problem
you're talking about instead the
analysts at the Digital Crimes Unit or
the Federal Trade Commission that we
cooperate with or other internal groups
so it's a smaller number of users but
the size of data are still very large a
needle in the haystack kind of problem
yeah it's exactly it's more targeted and
so with this problem it's a crime
problem but we need something that
people can use how can they understand
the vastness of this tech scam problem
how big is the problem where is it
occurring how many scams how organized
are the scams these are the kinds of
analysis questions that one can answer
with big data access and these kinds of
tools but we have to build them and so
we built a web crawling distributed
back-end infrastructure that would find
where these scams were happening online
one of the challenges was to find them
as they were happening and to capture
that because one detail around law
enforcement and digital crime is you
have to have evidence by building the
ability for people to organize this kind
of content organize it with provenance
with comparability with the ability to
query and reason we were able to then
start to build tools that analysts could
use the second half of that problem was
okay now we maybe have found all of this
content maybe we've started to use
machine learning and artificial
intelligence to structure it how do we
make that available to people how do we
make that
artificial intelligence visible and
usable well we have to build a bridge
and that bridges through user interfaces
or through HCI approaches in general and
so we had to build many of those and
organize them into an application and
make that available to these analysts
the outcome though was satisfying the
outcome was that we worked with the
Federal Trade Commission on operation
tech trap last year we were able to
supply them with the appropriate and
relevant information to contribute to
indictments and they levied several
indictments and raids and one of them
involved a group in Ohio that had been
defrauding 25,000 people of 40 million
dollars Wow
so the ability to go end-to-end to
identify the problem to organize the
technologies to find relevant permission
to make it accessible to an analyst and
then to matriculate those results into
action that to me is the real challenge
of the modern era of computing using
data and evidence-based decision-making
and so that's why our research focuses
on both that organizational aspect but
then also how do you present it how do
you make it navigable how do you make it
understandable and and cheap and it
seems like it'd be satisfying as well I
mean you've got all of that this huge
problem and then it the outcome is good
people were able to catch the bigger
fish using those kinds of absolutely
wait with those tools those are the
kinds of questions you can ask what is
the biggest fish what's the most recent
fish using that to stay ahead and work
at the speed and scale of those that are
doing exploitation that's the
opportunity and we're in a good position
to do it so let me ask you this because
it sounds like you're matching wits I
mean the people that are doing these
scams do they employ guys like you to do
the bad stuff and then you've got this
cat-and-mouse game of who's going to
stay ahead of whom in the big tech
picture one of the lessons I learned in
Afghanistan was that people are capable
of a lot people see movies they read
books but very few people really are
exposed to what humans are capable of
doing to each other and for money and so
the problem you mentioned this problem
of keeping up with the adversary
is also one of the limitations of the
work that we've done with the Digital
Crimes Unit is that it still has a
little bit of a whack-a-mole kind of
approach for trying to fight crime and
catch bad people and that is useful for
example it's useful for deterrence is
useful for characterizing the problem
but it has limitation in terms of the
long term Ness of its impact and so from
my point of view the other reason we
focus on the general-purpose Ness of the
technology is because the real impact in
those problems is likely to be one
through economics through understanding
how people are making money doing this
stuff and how to then use that as a way
to approach a more systematic way to
deal with the problem and so given all
of that to me it allows us to talk about
beyond the whack Amole approach beyond
the case-by-case approach because if we
think about how Spears of influence like
cyber and information are being used
systematically then we can start to
approach them with tactics and
understanding for example if we now see
that there are organizations that are
trying to influence groups of people we
can ask questions like how long does
that take what kind of measurement
system would we need to understand that
and if we had such a system such a big
data and technology measurement system
how might we use it to protect ourselves
it sounds like new fronts and new
frontiers
well I think what we're seeing with the
rise of the cloud and with the pervasive
increase in sensors collecting and
storing information is we're seeing how
people are starting to use that and in
the end a lot of this really is about
people and the way they're using it to
make money and exploit each other is
something that's really happening just
like people are also using it for
business purposes for a normal everyday
life yeah for just getting their work
done and so we have to acknowledge that
and make sure that we can protect our
platforms as a company book on trust as
the designated driver of the IT industry
has been recently reported and then at
the same time when we do see these
things happening how can we make sure to
empower the people that are protecting
us with the tools they need to make
decisions using permission
[Music]
you've been called the man who let the
dark web hmm
despite the sensationalism of that
headline how did you do that how did you
light the dark web I mean what was the
context of why they said that is a
better question well as I mentioned with
big data in general and the rise of
publicly accessible information and the
way it's being used now for both
exploitative purposes as well as
constructive purposes we were trying to
understand the right place to start
applying the technology we were
investing in from darkest point of view
and we looked around and we found to our
surprise that there was a tremendous use
of the internet and communication
networks on the Internet as a mechanism
for connecting buyers to their products
where the products were people and
that's the way I talked about it because
in the end it does seem to be a function
of economics that there is a demand for
products and they're willing to pay for
them and there is a supply and those are
people who are willing to take a risk
from law enforcement in order to make
money meeting demand and the way that
the Internet is used for advertising and
connecting the buyer in the product is
where there is both an opportunity as
well as a use that seems suspicious and
so when people are going online and
they're doing these searches some of
them are not looking for anything in
particular and then those that are
trying to look for something a little
bit more risky or a little bit more
dangerous start to find places online
where they are sought out and so our
view is that these places that are
before them a place where you could
operate with relative impunity because
no one could see what you were doing if
we could start to make it available for
people to see what you're doing
even without judging exactly whether
what you're doing is good or not because
that's what our you know legal system is
for is to help us make arbitrary
distinctions that at least then people
could have the evidence to know what you
were doing and then decide whether it's
worth prosecuting under our legal system
or not and that was the big opportunity
was that this darkness of different
types of networks of webpages of
usernames and large databases of FOIA
documents and leaks this darkness was
something where if we could make the
information within it visible to regular
people subject matter experts then maybe
they would do something about it and so
we took on the worst of the worst people
who were abusing children and who were
abusing women and men in labor and sex
situations and they were doing it a lot
and without really much consequence yeah
and so that was why we picked that
problem and I think that we had good
impact although there's still a lot of
work to do I really like the framework
of illuminating simply by putting a
light on something and then allowing
people to discern and follow up again oh
for sure well and when things are dark
and when things are vague or unknown
they can be scary because you don't know
their qualities yeah and once you start
to make something visible then you can
operate on it you can ask questions like
okay we're in you know New York and we
have a Special Victims Bureau and there
are 500,000 ads for sex in a year in
this jurisdiction how do we prioritize
who to go after how do we complement
that work with work and domestic
violence how do we understand what
hospital staff are needed what victim
outreach services these are analysis
questions analysis questions require the
granularity to answer them and from our
point of view a lot of that was
available online and so if we could
enable people to have access to it in an
understandable way then they wouldn't
have to make those decisions by gut
instinct or by precedent or by
highest-paid opinion they could put it
into a framework that let them evaluate
it in that way it wasn't even forever
they could make a decision they would
then have a measurement system to see
the effect of their decision and then
they could decide to keep doing it or
not
that to me was a much more maintainable
workable situation yeah and this is a
distinctly digital problem I mean the
ways that people communicated about
exploiting people or themselves for
money in the past were much more you
know seeable hmm and so now what you've
done is transfer that into this digital
realm and you're doing fingerprint
analysis in cyberspace absolutely if we
look at parts of the world where
physical security is still an issue
you'll see tall walls and razor wire
you'll see bars you'll see people with
machine guns in the information space in
the cyber space no such protections
really exist even here I mean very few
there's a large burden placed on
platform companies to protect our
customers in their data right and for
now if we want to proceed with business
if we want to have a market where people
have value assigned to the services we
offer including the trust of our
platform then we have to protect it well
it's often the case especially in the
research community that people think of
users in terms of novice and advanced I
just think that's the wrong approach
there are not novice and advanced users
there's really technical experts and
domain experts and domain experts know a
lot about what they're doing they know
the patrol they know their patients they
know their company they know the issues
they may not be comfortable with the
random variables or different AI
techniques but they certainly have been
doing something well for a while and
those are the kind of people that we
have to enable that we have to protect
we have to provide information to and
understanding that then also affects
research because you then design and
build for those people not just based on
what the literature says is an
innovation
[Music]
let's talk specifically about how the
background you brought the same
fundamental technological thinking but
applied in different areas and so it's
been useful in law enforcement useful in
the military useful in digital crime how
is it playing out now well our approach
to applied research is to take a look at
organizing data on one side creating
data structures using graph modeling
graph analytics graph statistics using
natural language processing and computer
vision basically turning streaming
access points have unstructured
information into a data structure that
one can work with and at the same time
bridging the gap to the user through
user interfaces through HCI that has AI
enabling it that combination is possible
partly because of our cloud but also
because of power bi power bi is a
excel-like tool for business
intelligence ostensibly but it's grown
and growing into more of a platform for
a data analysis the business
intelligence community was one that had
a dashboard approach to looking at
graphs of numbers and status updates but
it also was a marketplace where people
were going to be doing more complicated
kinds of analytics and so we used that
as our approach to organizing our
research and so we decided that we could
take that business intelligence market
and expand what that meant so that it
didn't just mean tables of numbers but
it meant metadata and graphs and streams
of content to do that we took the two
areas of our research streaming Garf
analytics and visual analytics with user
interfaces and we built them into power
bi we built them by enabling end-to-end
processes that would transform data
using AI techniques and we built them
using new visual representations for
interacting with content that was
something that allowed us to bridge the
gap between the
tract notion of AI the API notion of AI
the algorithmic notion of AI and more
like a real application experience and
the outcomes were quite useful and it
was a way that we found to take the
abstract notion of AI and make it
approachable and workable with something
that you can download and see and start
to work with but one part of the impact
was to me very important if the thing
you're building in research can only be
used by a fortune ten and costs millions
of dollars and requires a PhD in
computer science then there will be
limited impact by definition almost if
instead we want to enable a billion
people how do we get a billion people to
understand how to use data it's got to
be cheap and it doesn't require a PhD in
computer science and so to me that
outcome well it seems like an economic
or a business issue is actually to me a
research issue because it helps confirm
that as a priority we can still build
useful things but have the constraint of
low cost and ease of use
I've heard Microsoft research described
as a values forward organization and I
hear that over and over when I talk to
the researchers in this booth it's
interesting where you can marry business
interests with global good interests how
could we move toward making sure those
two stay married well my dad always
tells me that our goal is to do well by
doing good
and with Microsoft there's the
opportunity because of its position in
the marketplace because of its size
where things like trust things like
responsibility those things are core to
our business interests they're not just
company values but for me you know on
the research side I often ask
researchers you know what's a high-risk
project for you like how do you think
about risk because to me research is
where you should take risk which means
that you should do things that product
groups can't do can't afford is not on
their roadmap if we take research what
we can do is we can take risk and then
we can if successful make sure that the
rest of the company benefits and so this
problem of how do we do well in the
world
how do we address impacts to society how
do we approach problems that may have an
on market value at first well research
is a great place to take that risk
because when successful it helps the
company in many ways and there's room
for all kinds of people sometimes I
think about complicated research as like
baseball pitching where with baseball
occasionally one person can pitch nine
innings and succeed but often you need
three pitchers a starter a middle
reliever and a closer and they often
have to have different skills and so in
research the starter these are people
that have really original ideas that are
groundbreaking you know people like
yoshua bengio who works with us on deep
learning
they set the field for everyone else to
work in middle relievers they take work
and then they advance it to a useable
degree maybe and then closers they have
to have the patience to deal with the
tediousness of deployment and fielding
and the reality of operations right all
those skills are very necessary to stay
innovative and so we need those
different people and so to me having a
large research organization almost an
institution comprised of these different
kinds of people is the best chance we
have to stay innovative to stay on the
edge of what's relevant for society and
so make sure that Microsoft has
businesses of the future proving once
again that there's a baseball analogy
for everything listen I ask all the
researchers that come in this booth what
keeps you up at night I'm not even gonna
ask you that question because most of
the stuff you said at the beginning
keeps me up at night but I do want to
ask you as we close I wonder if you
could give some advice to aspiring
researchers who might look at you and
say what should I be thinking as I
plunge into what I'm gonna do after my
PhD right my point of view is that being
flexible being relaxed having an open
mind that those are really important
characteristics right before I went over
to Afghanistan there was this former
ster three-star general and he told me a
piece of advice he said that when I was
uncharged if i were organized if i was
on top of the situation
then I could really see an opportunity
walk in the door I could see it I could
take advantage of it and I could execute
on it
but if I was too concerned with my
position with my career with what I
thought of myself with my identity then
I would miss them and I really took that
to heart and it's not that there's one
way to approach any of these things but
I do think that given the pace of
Technology change in computer science
and given the role that's changing
between companies governments and
academic institutions that is very
important to have that kind of flexible
attitude because the thing that you
studied for a long time might be
irrelevant in three years and the locus
of action might change from one kind of
institution to another and so my point
of view is to roll with that and to take
advantage of those opportunities and
then to try to make it about the work
because when I make it about the work
then it's not about me and we can debate
about the work in ways we can measure
and then other people can contribute
things and if no one cares where that
comes from then the work can proceed and
that's to me also why I left DARPA I
wanted to make sure I could leave in
time for the work to survive my own
point of view because if it were good
enough then it should and if it requires
a single person's personality or
oversight then it's fragile and so I
would encourage any prospective
researcher to take a broad view of
research and to avoid getting stuck too
much on how they think of themselves and
their career and to say yes on that
third ask yeah yes and Chris White it's
been a delight thank you so much for
coming in and talking to us today happy
- thanks for having me
to learn more about dr. Chris lights and
how data science AI in the cloud are
solving big data problems at scale visit
microsoft.com/testlabguides
[Music]